un nuevo tiroteo en Estados Unidos esta
vez en California en paño de la
celebración del año nuevo chino en un
club nocturno
los bomberos acudieron al lugar y
atendieron a los heridos y declararon a
diez de las víctimas fallecidas en el
lugar hubo al menos 10 víctimas
adicionales que fueron transportadas en
numerosos hospitales locales
se enumeran en varias condiciones desde
estables hasta críticas el sospechoso
huyó de la escena y sigue pendiente
los hechos se registraron en Monterrey
Park una ciudad de 61.000 personas de
mayoría asiática o asiático americana
que queda a unos 13 kilómetros del
centro de Los Ángeles residentes de la
zona dijeron a los medios que vieron a
un hombre a la salida del lugar del
tiroteo portando un arma de largo
alcance otros siguen sorprendidos
tenía los auriculares puestos en ese
momento pero oí algunos sonidos y yo
estaba como son fuegos artificiales Ya
estaba triste porque pensé que nos los
perdíamos y supe que no eran fuegos
artificiales cuando oía el helicóptero
arriba porque nunca tenemos helicópteros
por aquí a menos que sea más en el lado
este de Los Ángeles
es muy sorprendente chocante escuchar
que algo así sucedió no solo en una
ciudad pequeña sino en mi ciudad nunca
piensas que le pasaría a tu pueblo o
algo así
la violencia Armada es un enorme
problema en Estados Unidos en 2022 se
produjeron 647 tiroteos masivos según el
sitio web gane
más de 44.000 personas murieron por
heridas de bala en 2022 de las cuales
más de la mitad fueron suicidios en el
país estima que uno de cada tres adultos
posee al menos un arma y casi uno de
cada dos adultos viven un hogar donde
hay un arma